taiwan walker on the mat for the mets
tonight
lasted just a third of an inning in his
last start in pittsburgh
six runs scored on his watch including a
couple while he was arguing with an
umpire he'll shake that off tonight
springer lofts one out to left field
it'll stay in the ballpark dom smith
eases back puts it away on the warning
track for the first down here's vladimir
guerrero jr banning second
impressive numbers across the board for
junior walker's got so many pitches that
he could use for seamer slider sinker
split curl a little bit of everything
that you're gonna have to do and deal
with
you're gonna have to early on figure out
if he's throwing them for strikes
third in the order
simeon one of only two position players
to have faced taiwan walker before he's
two for 14 against him the 01 pitch
bouncing ball towards third charged by
davis backhands near the bag throws to
first in time to get simeon guerrero
goes to second
so two men away once that ball gets into
jd davis's glove you know that he's
going to make a real good throw because
he has an absolute howitzer for an arm
here's t oscar hernandez over three last
night starts the day ninth in the
american league with the 295 batting
average
oh two coming
struck him out he went upstairs three
times in a row to strike out hernandez
and strand a pair nice job by taiwan
walker no score take on hunjin rio is
always pits well against the mets
start number 19 on the season for you
his last outing against texas was a
complete game
2-2
and nimo slices one out to left-center
back goes griel
back to the wall
nemo to second he's in standing with an
opposite field double durio was playing
way over toward the line and nimmo hit
it to straight away left and that was
good enough to get it by for his tenth
double of the year
[Music]
one and two catches the outside quarter
cold strike three ryu dropped that
changeup right on the outside corner
so here's the catcher james mccann he is
going in his 81st game of the season he
was over three last night
got robbed of a base hit possible double
when he grounded to third base having
vision made a nice play
and there's a line drive to left field
one hop right to curiel they're gonna
wave the runner home and guriel has
another outfield assist
tough to run on guriel especially in
that situation that ball was hit right
to him on a perfect hop
that was evidenced last night in his
first hit back when he hung in there and
found off several pitches and then got a
slow curve ball he slapped to left field
[Applause]
ground ball flight he's
got a little bit of a bobble and is
still going to be able to turn it
bloody guerrero's got a cannon for an
arm and he had a little trouble getting
that ball out of his glove but he gets
the ball to second back to first the
inning ending double play george
springer flying out deep to left field
his first time up he just missed hitting
a lead off home run 3-0 he rips one deep
down the left field line toward the
corner and that ball is gone springer he
missed the home run his first time up he
didn't miss it this time for george
springer
his
second career home run against taiwan
walker his eighth of the season and the
blue jays have snapped they met's
scoreless streak now tay oscar will step
in
there's an off speed pitch hit high and
deep and he went back to the soft stuff
and tail jumped all over it
the oscar hernandez a two-run shot his
14th of the season and the blue jays
have been a pair of home runs here in
the third
there's a fly ball into the gap springer
on the right
oh what a catch george springer's doing
it all tonight fully extended making an
absolutely remarkable grab to rob
brandon nemo of extra bases you're not
going to find a better catch than this
ground ball third baseman bobble
barbicio returned through in time
kevin biggio stayed with it
and made a terrific feed to second base
civilian with a good pivot and a double
play gets them out of the inning
[Applause]
that's going to get down if it doesn't
go out of the park it's off the fence
nimble plays it back in springer stops
at third and vladi guerrero
coasts into second with a line drive off
the fence in left runners at second and
third nobody out and marcus simeon
coming up
make sure you
you hit it hard somewhere
it's this one hard deep to left fifth
gear
get out of here and gone home run for
mark mississippi and what a battle for
symbiote on his 11th pitch of the at-bat
he hits a three-round home run his 24th
of the season fouled off a lot of really
tough pitchers from taiwan walker until
he got one to his liking but he doesn't
over swing he doesn't get long he just
shortens up his swing
2-2 to drury and he flicks one out to
right center field back toward the gap
springer and he drops the ball
made a third and drury pulls in at
second so after making an absolutely
spectacular catch in left center back in
the third inning springer drops a
catchable fly ball in right center so
now the mets with a chance to get on the
board second and third and one out for
nimmo broad more energized than they've
been all night and nimble lines with the
left field for a base saint that'll
bring in guillerme with the first met
run drury stops at third nemo three
times going to left field he's two for
three and the mets are on the board it's
now six to one where you was helped out
by his defense in the first four innings
springer unable to catch the fly ball by
drury helping the mets out here in the
fifth and pete wines one to left field
that's a base hit drury will come in
four straight hits for new york alonso
drives in a run and now it's six to two
toronto two runs home in the inning
dom is struck out in flight down looking
for his first hit in this series
and dom hits one through the hole that's
a base hit nimble being waved around
third he'll score without a throw three
runs home for the match of the fifth and
they've cut the toronto lead in half
hits six to three
he has walked single then grounded out
to blue jays with three home runs
though besides high and deep and way
back get out of here gone home run for
bo bishop make it four home runs for the
jays tonight no doubt about it bo got
every bit of
oh wow that hot shot by beau
took that one hopper and went the second
for the four south jd davis hit it hard
but the blues jays have been flashing
the leather tonight
or a base hit to left field he picks up
an rbi and simeon jogs in with the
eighth blue jay runs quite a contrast to
last night's over 18 for those five and
there's a drive to ride get up get out
of here gone pay oscar hernandez with
his second two-run home run of the ball
game
that's five home runs for the blue jays
tonight and they got their swagger back
for sure
yes
you saw
alonzo going to second base again on
defensive indifference just taking the
extra 90 feet
high fly ball into right britchik is
back and he is there under it and that's
the ball game